hey lelay just quick quick question did
you get my challenge
uh let me just say yes i got cause
i had like a game randomly start and i
didn't think i challenged like another
person but
just yes it is yes can you give me some
money yeah take your time
sounds good okay
okay so now i'll have to hype up my chat
too
um thanks people for sticking around
i guess i won't be using my green screen
do i reveal what's behind the green
screen
i could i have so many like secret
things behind the green screen be right
back
okay green screen has been
dethroned
it will rise again at some point
oh maybe i should i have her chat open
too and i could stream sniper chat
or is that that would just add another
layer of distraction
i think
oh she's excited yeah it's like before a
match i just try and stay
calm sometimes excitement will
make me it'll make me play out of my
my comfort zone but there's still hype
still hype okay do i play in england
i gotta start with something normal
right okay i'll play a budapest
i prepared this a little bit earlier
um now this is 3-2 so i'm gonna have to
try and focus on winning
over the board i saw she plays this line
now this is something i prepared off
stream
idea queen f6 coming hey
i appreciate the good luck bits
she's had this position twice in
chess.com games
both times she's taken and one of those
games her opponent played g5
the main move is queen f6
so the one time she had this position
she ran into g3
or she played g3 which is um
[Music]
which is a clear mistake
i'm trying to remember why i think g3 is
met with g5
and then black is better but this is a
really cool gambit
because um the queen
pressures so many different targets and
knight's a target king's a target
rook can eventually be a target if e3
i'll play g5
um so a lot of players will start
thinking here
now i will say this is dubious but like
in the blitz game
i'm gonna try and get away with it
i haven't had this position in a while
too
i used to play this a lot in in bullets
and even against strong players like
it's not clear
it's not clear what white should do
because black's gonna get a ton of
initiative
oh did i stop all her hype i may have
that's the thing like you have to kind
of be ready to just
be really really focused um
but now i'm feeling the hype like it's
it's all still prep
still theory and dubious theory
the thing is like a lot of the best
moves for white are natural moves
but it looks scary so um it's easy to
just spend all the time making sure
things are not a blunder
so i'm threatening to play h for
trapping the bishop
uh if white ever takes i'll be happy to
develop the knight
i'll still have the thread of h4
uh why you could play h4 okay
so this is uh yeah this is still
preparation h4 is one of the
better moves h3 is still completely fine
so it's important to note my rook is
defended
and now we might get some really strange
structure
it's all still prop i've been playing
this for
like probably close to a decade on and
off
um so this is looming this is still
this pawn is undefended
this is a target
this is a good lesson for her though
because i'll show her like afterwards
how to deal with this opening
um yeah i think i should take on g4
first leaving the tension
i want the king to be here because now
both knights are pinned
queen c2 is a good move
um okay maybe i'll take and then regain
the pawn
and then like somehow it'll be equal
material
so only issue is this is a massive
threat
oh maybe i could wait a minute okay
i take my time here i'm no longer in
prep
i could take on f3 first preventing
queen e4 and after takes i take here
and then i check or check here
like i want to think and then blitz out
the next like four or five moves
queen h4
yeah let's put this out
queen each four it's unclear where the
king moves
i mean queen e4 still might be coming
um i'm gonna have to win
[Music]
the pawn
hmm
yeah we trade i'm looking for ways to
keep queens on the board
i guess i could take on d2
but then i don't want to lose my bishop
okay so we're going to trade i'll play
bishop e7 go for f5
oh f5 was a maybe mistake there's knight
g3 as well
i have c6 here
a fair move
it's probably like still completely fine
for white
uh if i take
i could also i'm considering f4 here
i'll play a 4 97 coming
yeah the rook really wants to enter the
game
so there's two fully open files between
the d and the h file
develop the bishop knight d6 i just play
king c7
now the knight wants to come to e5 first
i should
probably avoid any rook train
there's this tricky move
yeah i kind of saw that coming
i was preparing this but then knight i
guess 98 king
d8 looks okay
she's playing playing well
i like the position still
wait i can win the pawn took me a moment
to spot that
now these pawns are weak
uh there's some
i tricks it's all okay i might even play
this move first
threatening to take and then triple fork
bad at drawing arrows but as long as i
can make the moves
yeah so triple fork
and now i'm still threatening with
everything basically
there we go and i'll pin and win
okay that was a nice game i was uh i
mean she played well to kind of get out
of the opening
with a fair position but the time
time was kind of a determining factor
okay let me unmute myself
relay did you want to analyze
okay okay so
can you hear yep i can hear you i just
um
i think i just invited you to analysis
board
yes okay so that so this is one of the
like very few openings i prepared
right before i started streaming
and i saw you had a few games in this
line
and this is like one of the best lines
for white in the in the against the
budapest
is this bishop f4 move yes
um but
yeah it's hard to play this as white if
you haven't seen this before
because there's like so many targets yes
i have never seen that
really yeah i found i think one game you
had this position you played g3
um e3 is the best move
and really what white should do here is
just kind of weather the storm
h3 is fine h4 is probably
um easier to play
because then you just prevent me
completely from playing
h4 myself yes and uh
i would have i would still try and set
up tricks like
after takes takes i would take on b2
and threaten to take on d2 and then when
you're rook
but you'll always have enough moves to
defend like not f3
and if you can just kind of develop and
not blunder anything then my king is
very weak
and that's almost what happened
the problem was i became confused
because i have never played like my
opponents had
never played queen f6 and i needed to
think and then and also like everything
was hanging ever was hanging
vito was hanging also and it was quite
tough for me to find really good move
here
so yeah yeah it's um
it's just it's just one of those things
i guess if you're if you
would go into this line again you should
just have some knowledge of what to do
um i think like the the best
move like the so-called refutation is
knight h3
which uh it's very hard to find if
you've you've never actually seen this
um i've encountered this once against uh
i actually played dimitri komarov in an
online game and he knew this move
um but you you almost fought back there
like
uh you're able to trade queens i think
it was like equal end game
but uh it's tough just having having to
live on the increment
uh yes the problem was my time because
like i spent my time to like
uh think in the middle okay what should
i
i mean now i was thinking yes i had um
i had normal end game quality but then i
blended my opponent on c4 so
right yeah if you had a little bit more
time um like i could have even
been worse here uh there was this moment
i think knight g3
could have been very strong like hitting
f5 and
only moved to the fender five is to
basically overextend
but anyway that was a i guess a
feel-good game for
for me with opening um now
it's a good game to have i guess from
your perspective so you you'll have a
better idea what to do for next time
but i think you're not gonna play this
again
i'm gonna try some other like tricky
gambits but
the problem is i was thinking that yo
you are playing such kind of games or
like three components it's on and
i was like uh i was really afraid that
you
if you would trick me and so like this
calculation is pretty tough in just
three plus zero
right yeah and this this was the line i
was most excited to play because i've
i saw that there's very good chance he
would go into it